do you want to apologize to me I know
who I know I know asking you to
apologize apologize for what you just
got shown up by the hosts that you
smeared me by the saying that I was
trying to get out of something or change
the goal posts you you're trying yes you
were trying because now look we're
getting down to brass tacks here it
looks like he's not showing up I worried
about eating the hat so you're trying to
just kind of like I'll change the
language or not I just said if he did
the same thing I said the first day what
have I said differently what have I said
differently unless you if you want to
troll this to say you're trolling that's
fine we can get we can just move past
that and get to Albert barese I mean I
think we should just get to Albert hi
Albert how are you sir you there Albert
brew
I'm doing great rich and I'm gonna like
I heard you guys laughing at the end and
I wasn't paying attention so I'm sorry
it's all good well I guess you will
start off our conversation Albert Brewer
of the mmq be here on the Rich Eisen
show I said to Mike tell to faux when
Zeke didn't show up at Cowboys camp that
if he is a healthy guy on a planet not
suspended and he's got every ability to
be the starting running back for the
Dallas Cowboys but if he's not there as
a starting running back because he's
holding out I would eat the hat off of
Mike del 2fo said I'm genuinely
concerned about that do I eat ahead in
week one of the NFL season do you think
I think eventually there's going to come
to an agreement and I think it probably
happens before week one just based on
the Cowboys track record in history
loosening this bluster before we've seen
the back and forth publicly before
because everything is public with the
Cowboys you know and ultimately I can't
come up with too many examples that I'm
not getting yields done and we saw this
sort of back-and-forth between the team
and DeMarcus Lawrence in the spring
ultimately that one got done that was a
difficult deal to do to I was over 20
million a year you know ultimately I
think where the Cowboys are now is close
to what Todd Gurley got I think if push
comes to shove they may be willing to
inch past what Todd Gurley got and if
they do that I think it's going to be
very difficult
get to walk away look I know how
valuable he is I know what sort of
weapon he is I know you know he may look
at Julio Jones getting 20 or 21 or 22
million dollars in the next few weeks
and say I deserve to be paid like that
guy you know but ultimately he's running
back and those guys agent dog ears and
so if he's offered something that the
tick more and what taught girl yet my
sense is he had probably accepted do you
see any sort of foreseeable fix for
whatever is going on with Melvin Gordon
and the Chargers however Albert I think
that one's more difficult you know I
looked I did the offer like the Chargers
have put on a table of the fair one
right in the ten million dollar per year
range I think you know Melvin Gordon's
opinion of himself is probably a little
inflated and I think the issue he has is
the issue a lot of running backs have
and and here's why I think Zeke and
girly and you know safe on I think those
guys are in different categories you
know the new prototypes or the running
back in the NFL 225 pounds guy who can
play on all three downs and the top tier
in the NFL at that position is much
smaller than it is other positions right
there's only a few guys like that and
then the second tier is much larger than
it is another fish to the tops here
I think boards in the second tier and we
saw that with how the Chargers were able
to replace them last year and so you
know I think Gordon's scored resolved to
make a stand here and I don't think he's
getting paid would necessarily help
matters between him and the team I also
know the Chargers are pretty strong in
their stance you know and where they are
right now and feeling that what they
have on the table is pretty fair and so
I would not be surprised one bit of Ford
pulled out last in the season I think
it's more likely than he's holed up
going into the season all right then
let's complete the trifecta of the I
guess off the field stories that many
people have been talking about in the
NFL and that's the the helmet affair for
Antonio Brown he is in Canada I do
believe right Chris Brock when he's in
Canada right now with the team to take
on the Packers tonight I think
helmets are 10% more potent up there in
Canada so we'll see engine I don't think
he's gonna get out there tonight but
just the fact that he's there doesn't
mean that this is all over right I mean
where do things stand right here on this
front they still gotta figure out what
helmet he's gonna wear when the season
starts
but I but I do think that the worst is
in the rearview mirror and I think a big
part of this is the way the Raiders sort
of stood by him you know and outside of
Mike doing what he did in that Sunday
where you know he kind of drew along a
line in the sand the Raiders have very
much you know been in in a navies corner
on this I think he understood why Mayock
did what he had to do there and you know
I just tell you rich like the Berdych
like like you hear coming out there and
when we talk to people in that
organization last year versus this year
is 100% different last year I remember
talking to John looking about the roster
and this is wrong and that's wrong
wieszczyk cyst we need to fix that you
know we don't have a chance if it
doesn't happen and this year you go
there and there's just more ownership of
everything there's more ownership of
every player in the roster and I think
that's a subtle but obvious difference
if you're looking for it where you
really see where Bruton has embraced
Antonio Brown as his and I agree with a
parent on Hard Knocks the other night
and certainly I think it's a parent's
day Antonio Brown and how he's handle
this whole thing say yeah but the one
part of Antonio Brown on hard knocks
that I would love to have seen and I
understand perhaps why we didn't wear it
was what in fact did happen to go from
the hunky-dory they're kind of strolling
off together the practice field Antonia
Brown and Jon Gruden like the end of
Casablanca right and and it's the
beginning of a beautiful friendship and
then he doesn't show up the next day and
Mayock shows up at the media tent to
talk about all in all out there's 89
guys there's one other guy what in the
world happened there and and and when
you say the worst is over is that all
bottled up like because nobody saw him
being unmodeled over that 24-hour period
we didn't see the deliberations that led
to Mae ox showing up at the media tent
well he lost his grievance is what
happened
and you know I think that whatever
delusion he had about that because I
think most people didn't think he had a
shot at winning the grievance you know
losing the grievance I think was sort of
what caused a lot of that and I realized
this realization that you know he was
going to have to go out there in a
different element and I know it sounds
fought all of us but the one thing I
think anyone in the Steeler organization
that that dealt with in the last nine
years to tell you it's always the little
things that set a bee off and if you
want to look back to the last year not
one a team MVP award is what caused him
to storm off in week 17 and missed that
last game of the year with the playoffs
on the line and so it just always been
that way with him where little things
whether there's fight for you or you
feel disrespected whatever it might be
like those little things have always
been the things that have set him off
and I think for the Raiders here's the
thing he isn't he is he's in his 30s you
paid him he gave him thirty million
dollars guarantee you know what you
signed up for and so you know I think
his reaction to this sort of thing while
it seems weird when you take kind of in
a vacuum really falls in line with
everything that he wasn't historic and
the issues of the field I've had with
them and so I think you know Mike did
what he had to do getting out there and
saying like we're not going to be
feeling with this on a day-to-day basis
this way but I think that the Raiders
also do this is a part of what they
signed up for when they traded form last
year well the before but then before we
move on on from this then Albert is is
there is another grief yes that's coming
right over whether he can well over
whether he can get the one-year grace
period for his helmet that everybody
else that had red helmets last year got
last year and the arbiter I guess was
hearing this will have to decide is that
a rolling one rolling one-year grace
period for whoever raises their hand and
say hey I want to wear a red helmet now
that wasn't tested the year before if
suddenly somebody raised their hand
saying I want to wear a leather helmet
give me a one-year grace period on that
you know obviously I'm using an extreme
example so there's another two grievance
coming and there's one thing I haven't
really seen any specific
reporting on what is his issue with the
helmet like the new helmet like why
doesn't what what exactly is it is it
because I'm hearing it that that field
of vision is an issue another thing that
I saw on Hard Knocks is it sounded like
he thought it just didn't look good like
it just he didn't look good in it or
didn't look good or cool yeah um what is
it do we know yeah and you know like I
think field of vision is definitely an
issue I know that came up with for 82
and you know Brady has and one thing
that's sort of gone unreported here
Brady has gone back and forth with
helmets over the last five or six years
like if you look if you look really
closely over the last five or six years
you can find individual games where
Brady switched out of the helmet that
he's worn the model that he's won really
since he was a rookie into other helmets
and then ultimately you know we could -
later he'll he'll switch back I think
it's much say anything else it's a
comfort thing and you know I think that
there's a lot that plays into comfort
for players there's the whole you know
Dion saying you look good you play good
you play good you pay good right so
there's that part of it I think it's a
piece of all of this and then I think
that the functionality of the helmet too
is a part of it just you know feeling
like yourself out there you know and so
I think that again this plays back into
that little thing set him off you know
he is very particular about the way he
trains he's very particular about the
way that he look he's very particular
about everything it's just who he is
part of who we make of what masonry is
is a player and so I think it would like
you know my feeling on it too having
talked to people who have been involved
in this is that it's just it's a comfort
issue that sort of encapsulate a lot of
those different things that that they go
into you know players comfort level out
there on the field they're wearing
Albert Brewer the mm QB right here on
the Rich Eisen show Albert last time we
saw you when you were here in studio and
you were more bronze than the busts that
we saw later on that week and Canton you
went through all your training camps
that's how you got that nice George
Hamilton the tan that you got going on
you talked about Andrew Luck you just
seen him and how the leg was beginning
to bother him more
and than anybody thought it would now
here we are preseason week three he's
not even practicing Albert what's going
on here good luck
oh I I regret to inform you that Sam
sort of worn off now Brad I know I know
I know I I would I would tell you like
the Colts have been pretty upfront about
this stuff both both both silently and
publicly yeah like III think that
there's an element of just not knowing
exactly what it was
you know they referred to it as a calf
when I sat down with Andrew a camp he
kept referring to it as his ankle and
even when I brought up the idea of the
calf injury he kind of pivoted back to
ankle and you know the the nomenclatures
that they used with me when you know I
made some calls on it about a week ago
was we need to just let this thing calm
down and so you know you put the pieces
together and you say calf and ankle and
you know the wording calmed down you
know a lot of times of athletes that
plays into Achilles but I don't think
they're 100% sure you know what they
unless I'm not I'm not a percent sure
they know exactly what they're looking
at and so you know that piece of it I
think been frustrating for the team has
been frustrating for the player and and
the other thing that I would mention
here with luck he completely overhauled
his mechanics last year he worked with
Tom house now data those guys out there
in Orange County because sort of we make
his delivery a little bit coming off the
shoulder surgery and part of the idea
there was you know we're gonna make sure
that this doesn't happen again but
there's you know but by its like
tightening up his throwing motion and
cleaning up his mechanics and you know
sometimes that can lead to other
problems so I you know I I hesitate to
point the finger there but you know that
could be another area where you could be
looking at something where it's like you
know one thing maybe threw off another
and now you've got a problem somewhere
else where you were trying to take care
of the previous problem before I let you
go Albert I started the show by saying
six preseason games tonight and you've
got guys that normally we would see play
the
our first half into the third quarter
Brady Rodgers Ryan obviously Cam Newton
just off the top of my head obviously
with the collective bargaining agreement
conversations going on behind the scenes
and you know I'm told that there's more
bargaining sessions set for next week
and the conversation of the preseason
being on the line and what we've seen
already we're hardly anybody's playing
give me a top-down look on what we're
gonna be seeing tonight in general about
the the future of the preseason alert
well there are a couple things so I mean
you know obviously the rookie
quarterbacks I think are always center
stage for the preseason so getting to
feel a little more of being on Jones in
New York and Wayne Haskins and in
Washington you know that there are some
reasons still to come in that's I think
in a conversation I was a coach about
this and his approach to it he was from
a team that had two sets of joint
practices so you know two joint
practices one team two joint practices
with another team he told me he's like
you know there's a ton of benefit for me
to just put my guys out there here and
not put them out there in the preseason
games explained I get fifty game reps in
each of these practices for my starters
so that's a total of 200 game preps
which is more than they will get a
typical pretty season schedule all four
games these and on top of that we get to
run all our wheel stuff like we're not
holding stuff back because this tape
isn't going out to anyone else and so
we're going to run all the stuff we're
going to run in the regular season and
we get to test stuff out you know based
on what we want to see and what we want
to see from guys ahead of week one in
that environment is a great benefit
right then you get to control it and so
you know that cuts down the chance
there's going to be a catastrophic
injury out there you know and then you
know you're working with the other
coaches so there's opportunity to maybe
generate matchups and work together with
the other team to see certain guys in
certain spots and so his whole point was
you put all that together
he's like why would I expose my players
to anything in the preseason
when I've got the opportunity to get
them out there in these joint practices
and get a much better look a better
environment you know better you know a
better chance to get a look at our real
team all that stuff but yeah why would I
play these guys in three season games
get that in the joint practices and
still rich I think the answer here is
finding a way to market those joint
practices because those are a great
thing for the fans to I don't know if
you've been to any of them but they're a
great thing for the fans to the coaches
love them so maybe there's a way out
there where they can find a way to
market pop it off the joint practices
have each team do at least a couple of
those and maybe that's the way that you
take a couple of preseason games on the
schedule certainly I don't think anybody
looks at preseason games and says that's
the product the NFL wants to put out
there Albert now before I let you go and
do you have anything on Patrick Chung
other than just the news that came out
of New Hampshire I broke in the last
hour yeah it's very clear like that this
was you know something that happened a
couple months ago and it was a report
out there about this being part of a
larger drug raid you know there's some
back and forth there but you know
clearly like the Patriots have already
is that they're looking into it I mean
look it's not what you're looking for on
the day the third preseason game
certainly do this topic up in here in
Boston over the next couple of days
Albert great stuff as always check out
Albert's 32 notes from 32 NFL training
camps none of the notes about
unfortunately his fading raging ten that
he got doing all that good to chat with
you Oliver
get out there and work on that for you
rich always always enjoy our chats we'll
chat soon okay but thank you got it
that's Albert Brett at Albert Breyer on
Twitter for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app